what are strengths and limitations of
cameras for the driving test in your
understanding when you formulate the
driving task as a vision task with eight
cameras
you've seen that the entire you know
most of the history of the computer
vision field when it has to do with
neural networks what just if you step
back what are the strengths and
limitations of pixels of using pixels to
drive yeah pixels I think are a
beautiful sensory beautiful sensor I
would say the thing is like cameras are
very very cheap and they provide a ton
of information ton of bits so it's a
extremely cheap sensor for a ton of bits
and each one of these bits as a
constraint on the state of the world and
so you get lots of megapixel images very
cheap and it just gives you all these
constraints for understanding what's
actually out there in the world so
vision is probably the highest bandwidth
sensor it's a very high bandwidth sensor
and um
I love that pixels it is uh is a
constraint on the world This is highly
complex
uh high bandwidth constraint in the
world on the stage of the world it's not
just that but again this real real
importance of it's the sensor that
humans use therefore everything is
designed for that sensor yeah the text
the writing the flashing signs
everything is designed for vision and so
and you just find it everywhere and so
that's why that is the interface you
want to be in
um talking again about these Universal
interfaces and uh that's where we
actually want to measure the world as
well and then develop software uh for
that sensor but there's other
constraints on the state of the world
that humans use to understand the world
I mean Vision ultimately is the main one
but we're like we're like referencing
our understanding of human behavior and
some common sense
physics that could be inferred from
vision from from a perception
perspective but it feels like we're
using some kind of reasoning
to uh predict the world yeah not just
the pixels I mean you have a powerful
prior uh sorry right for how the world
evolves over time Etc so it's not just
about the likelihood term coming up from
the data itself telling you about what
you are observing but also the prior
term of like where what are the likely
things to see and how do they likely
move and so on and the question is how
complex is the uh
the the range of possibilities that
might happen in the driving task right
that's still is is that to you still an
open problem of how difficult is driving
like philosophically speaking
like do you all the time you've worked
on driving do you understand how hard
driving is yeah driving is really hard
because it has to do with the
predictions of all these other agents in
the theory of mind and you know what
they're going to do and are they looking
at you are they where are they looking
what are they thinking yeah there's a
lot that goes there at the at the full
tail off you know the the expansion of
the nines that we have to be comfortable
with eventually the final problems are
of that form I don't think those are the
problems that are very common uh I think
eventually they're important but it's
like really in the tail end in the tail
and the rare edge cases
from the vision perspective what are the
toughest parts of the vision problem of
driving
um
well basically the sensor is extremely
powerful but you still need to process
that information
um and so going from brightnesses of
these pixel values to hey here the
three-dimensional world is extremely
hard and that's what the neural networks
are fundamentally doing and so
um the difficulty really is in just
doing an extremely good job of
engineering the entire pipeline uh the
entire data engine having the capacity
to train these neural nuts having the
ability to evaluate the system and
iterate on it uh so I would say just
doing this in production at scale is
like the hard part it's an execution
problem so the data engine but also the
um the sort of deployment of the system
such that has low latency performance so
it has to do all these steps yeah for
the neural net specifically just making
sure everything fits into the chip on
the car yeah and uh you have a finite
budget of flops that you can perform and
uh and memory bandwidth and other
constraints and you have to make sure it
flies and you can squeeze in as much
compute as you can into the tiny what
have you learned from that process
because it maybe that's one of the
bigger like new things coming from a
research background
where there's there's a system that has
to run under heavily constrained
resources right has to run really fast
what what kind of insights have you uh
learned from that yeah I'm not sure if
it's if there's too many insights you're
trying to create a neural net that will
fit in what you have available and
you're always trying to optimize it and
we talked a lot about it on the AI day
and uh basically the the triple
backflips that the team is doing to make
sure it all fits and utilizes the engine
uh so I think it's extremely good
engineering
um and then there's also all kinds of
little insights peppered in on how to do
it properly